two powerful winter storm systems are
targeting tens of millions of people
across the u.s. this morning heavy snow
and high winds are causing blizzard
conditions in parts of the plains and
Upper Midwest some places have up to
nine inches of snow and more is falling
fast
oh boy to the east crews are scrambling
to repair downed powerlines ahead of
another massive winter storm more than
two hundred thousand customers are still
without electricity today after last
week's deadly nor'easter the system is
forming off the coast and we'll reach
the Northeast later today it will bring
heavy snow and wind gusts up to 60 miles
per hour
DeMarco Morgan is in Sandwich
Massachusetts where coastal flooding is
a major concern
DeMarco good morning good morning guys
just take a look at what's left of this
home right here you can see through the
first level and also up through the
basement this happened as a result of
last week's storm that caused up to 90
miles per hour wind gust and also
historic coastal flooding along with
dangerous storm surge and get this more
than 300 homes along the coast are at
risk for this latest storm that's headed
our way now a nearby Duxbury 30% of the
seawall is compromised they are also
concerned about flooding in that area as
well and when you talk about the
communities that are not on the water
they are worried about power outages and
nearly 20,000 are still without power as
a result of last week's storm and they
won't get their power restored until
sometime this weekend so the waiting
begins back to you another unit for the
Northeast and Marco thank you